are you tired of the same old xbox one
controller I'm sorry to say that the
elite models are sold out pretty much
everywhere it'll be tough to get your
hands on the shiny new controllers
pretty ironic if you ask me the Xbox one
elite controller costs 150 bucks but
retailer is like amazon best buy
gamestop target and even microsoft
itself are completely sold out one fan
actually tweeted xbox boss Phil Spencer
about finding one to which the big man
responded I'm glad you found one we keep
shipping more in but they sell out
instantly but don't give up just yet you
can always pick up the Xbox one elite
model which includes the special
controller and a sweet one terabyte hard
drive that will set you back 450 bucks
but it's a good deal if you haven't
bought into Microsoft's current console
generation yet just do it before
december 26 it goes back up to 500 after
christmas for more on the best-selling
controller you can check out our first
look and hands-on impressions and you
can stick around gamespot for all your
xbox one needs this is Tony signing out